I want
to eat ramen I want to eat ramen Thank you for waiting
[music]
She eats ramen with
courage
[Music]
duane
[Applause]
amaran
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
But the temple doesn't have any kind of foreigner, so you
can say that she tried shiho for the first time
.
Mmm
[music
] Hey, I've been
sent miso Poo, so I think I
'll look
at it.
Dora doesn't keep quiet and
it feels cold, or
rather,
I've never even talked to him.
It's impossible for Airi to be cute Ah ah
Yes Misa is also cute
Already I'm sorry I'm going to buy a mini-car for clothes  I don't know what to do with the aurora today What should I do with
food
I wonder if it's a
convenience store?
Alone I'm standing in line over there Uh
a too
yes
What is this situation
?
I haven't been able to talk to you until now, but I
wonder if you know that Koizumi-san I'm in the same class as
Yu Osawa
.
Well, it's not something
you eat, ah, ah, it's amazing, I've been unnecessarily fond of the eyes around me,
and this guy comes to this store a lot today
.
Discovery is like a school cafeteria
Then I'm the same
[music] It's my
first time at a ramen shop on the way home from school Can I
put garlic on the left side?
I got it
right tan
6 just bath vegetables more garlic oil
caramel is automatic
9 and good
noodles
[music]
was
buzzer double vegetables are also skinny
]
Yeah yeah yeah me [music] huh huh yeah yeah yeah [music] And how happy you are in the past oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh, what a
ben
voodoo amount
Ramen is pouring out of every hole in my body  It
's the
first time
I've ever wondered if he's a regular customer, but I think
Mr. Koizumi is a ramen
lover.
Tell me, I
wo
n't tell you. I just want to keep this really good restaurant a secret to myself
.
This is the story
of Mr. Koizumi,
who loves ramen.
Eat
Yes
I wonder if it's refreshing today
What are you looking at
ana I
wonder if Koizumi is watching We've
already eaten ramen together, but I think I'll look at the one in the thread
Umabun After all, Mr. Koizumi likes ramen
Occasionally at lunch
I want to eat ramen that is not served in the school cafeteria
.
Let's become friends Please cooperate with the plan The
late Mr. Yashiro is a
special product
.
I don't like it, 23 is
cute enough Come on,
Koizumi or Ikumi-san,
it's peaceful today
[music]
Good
.
It's not my house,
so I'll let you do that
Mr. Koizumi is the same. I'm also new to Kumamoto
Rane.  Hey, at
that store, they just
speed up their eating as much as possible to keep the rotation of the lot from going bad
.
That's right, this horse oil has a nice flavor. I didn't know that
horse oil goes so well with pork bone soup.
In this case, it is called Seika instead of horse oil.By the
way, unlike the horse oil used in cosmetics,
ramen dance is
a flavored oil made by burning garlic to transfer the scent.
Sara Tori is a
Kumamoto-style soup that uses a mix of pork bones and chicken bones, and
is characterized by a richer flavor than that of Kurume's beloved brother, who has its roots in Kurume
.
When it comes to authentic cocoons, the garlic flavor is
stronger, and I'd like to have it in the form of chips.
It's
common.When I eat there, I ask for one eye.It's a girlish
and cute voice
[music]
Koizumi Say
, did you go to the pottery to eat ramen?
I want to try that shop's ramen
.
ka
pop Hey
shhh ni
Koizumi
[music]
Mr. Koizumi is
coming to the ramen shop again today
.
Choice +
Colored set meal
After all, I want to eat a lot regardless of the bottom 3
I tie my beautiful hair and patch my battle stance
Itadakimasu yes itadakimasu Oh this is richer
than I expected 5 Thick
noodles in muddy soup Netley
[music]
Ramen  Mr. Koizumi who eats is
still happy.
I didn't think I'd
go to Koizumi-san to eat noodles,
so please read Fur Talker Love.  One of them is
delicious, isn't it?
Even so, this soup is really thick, is
n't it? This white texture
is for the mayor.
It's a
completely different fault from the Kumamoto tonkotsu I had before, but of
course, this soup is based on
chicken bones.
The soup is cloudy, but the pork bones are transparent, and the
soup
is salty brown.
Mr. Wada
's classification of pork bones and other classifications by whom.
There are many things that are difficult to describe
in one
word.  4 Korat with plenty of
goragen  I
'm going to drink it all up, Bach,
and I'm not going to have a soup
.
I've been waiting for this
moment Chakudon 5 First, I ate half of the stool,
and while snacking on rice and side dishes, I
won at once when the potch noodles were completely soaked in the soup
[Music]
Personally, this is the best way to eat
Oh  At stores that offer a free boiled egg service, I crush the eggs and
throw them in. The taste is exactly like
carbonara ramen, which makes me want to eat it once a week. It's so
addictive.
I
was with Koizumi-san, who said that I didn't feel like my skin had become glossy due to the effects of
yesterday's collagen. I went to eat ramen with him.
There is, isn't there
Koizumi-san, who
will
be appointed together
today?
eaa
[music]
Waiting isn't enough I've realized that I've shared
it and I've met you, so I'll
take it indifferently and go to sleep 51
Live watch me, bustling
town tan
can you
[music]
do me
hanime
[music]
uh
me
[music]
[applause]
can't help me
[music]
me
ni
ani
[music]
[applause]
meme
it just hurts
It takes a lot of
courage, doesn't it?
Mr. Koizumi seems to be totally okay with that kind of thing, and it's
cool.